[Music]
we' got enemy activity
nearby
[Music]
hey everybody how's it going I'm John
Luke and I'm joined by Spencer here
Spencer how's it going what's going on
guys uh we are playing Ghost Recon
wildlands the open Beta it started uh
earlier today right yeah it started
earlier today a lot of people have been
having some connection issues but
luckily for us we finally got in cool uh
let's just join a public match let's get
right into
it all right suers for those wondering
yes this is an open Beta so it is uh you
could just download it although it's
taken uh takes a while so download it
now so it's ready for later tonight if
you want to play it uh I am going to be
checking the chat so feel free to hit us
up with any questions you have uh and
yeah let's see if we can get in a match
here let's see hopefully we can yeah so
you said it's been fine on your end it's
been fine on my end uh it took about I
would say an hour after the uh beta
launch that I was able to finally
connect and I've stayed connected since
then okay so you know what while we're
doing this I'll just cancel this we can
just jump right into the into the game
itself yeah do
it oh wait nope that's not what I wanted
oh Ming error uh oh okay that error is
actually what people have been seeing a
lot lately okay
so if that happens to us again we'll
just run around because actually there's
a new section of the map now opened up
in this open Beta that wasn't available
in the Clos beta so do you still have
the previous map available uh yes you
still have the previous area which is I
believe we're in now I see here we go so
I'll just hold
down so yeah so we can just goof around
while the game oh you're searching
awesome yeah so let's see here the game
audio a little bit here yeah so this
area here s yes we just started
streaming Sor this area is new here so
okay cool cool fast travel here yeah's
check out all the new
stuff it's so it's such a grind though
to connect to this game sometimes like
it's yeah it's fun to play but it
definitely takes some a little luck to
finally connect to
[Music]
it
do you feel
um I definitely felt the game was a
little unpolished at that uh Clos beta
yeah it it definitely felt on polished
to me too uh feel any better here yeah I
feel it feels a little better here like
there's definitely some a little better
textures and the frame rate isn't
hurting too much okay that's good so
this is NAD boots down in Monte what
have you got for us Monte is Santa
Blanca's primary he's no fixing that
dialogue though I'm still St train c not
doing for all over Amica it's not tough
enough for you andur ising big money to
bring people background cartel recruits
the senior instructor is rumored to be
former US military but we don't know
much more than that seems like a lot of
people in the uh chat have been having
issues with the beta Cowman you're not
the only ones like everyone all over the
world is having is we Mark so the rebels
can pick up these supplies later once
you are connected uh motor from my
experience you stay connected but it's
getting connected that's been the major
issue for a lot of people so cuz as I
said when I first loaded this thing in
and got about uh I had to wait about an
hour before it finally connected to me
and since then I have I've been able to
you know click on and off on and off
since
so uh shanyi yes this is multi Coop
online uh does it have split screen uh
I'm not sure I don't think so I think
not uh I yeah
see if we can go up here still trying to
find us a group to join with so all
right well let's just try and do some
missions on our own then while we
hopefully eventually connect to
somebody
anybody all right let's see you know
what goes up the road let's go got to J
back for a
reason see like for me the frame rate in
the Clos beta was like kind of chugging
at times especially at points like this
when you're on a bike sure right now to
me it's not it's not showing that too
badly so there's been some improvements
I played on PC I didn't really have that
many issues but I have a pretty B PC at
home so I think I just sort of Bo forced
it to be uh pretty good is there an
armored vehicle up here I can take ooh
there is an armored vehicle I can take
although I couldn't run it at Max
settings um I have a 1070 okay and which
is not the highest in graphics card but
I tried to run it Max settings and it
did uh who leaves a tank I did not love
it not that I'm
complaining yeah get in that tank
man come on
guys someone asked what's the frame rate
uh the frame rate on Console I would say
probably a solid 30 yeah I would say
it's a solid 30 as well
um yeah I would definitely AG to that
for sure oh we are playing this on PS4
for anyone wondering right now uh but
the beta is available on all three
platforms to download uh someone in the
chat was saying apparently it's 25 gigs
to download on uh steam the uh yes I
think so I know that if you have the
closed damn it I know if you have the
closed uh beta and you try to download
this update it actually requires it's a
19 gigabyte on PS uh 4 so it kind of
overrides the close beta and adds the
new stuff from this to that interesting
so this thing is really hard to drive
that's another thing unfortunately
haven't quite quite yet the is the
driving controls in this for me not
great everything it just I don't know it
just feels weird like I know they're
trying to customize the controls to fit
like oh you driving a tank so it's going
to be a lot harder to turn but if you
make it to the point where it's not fun
to drive I think it kind of loses the
point yeah I I messed around with I
found helicopters really weird to drive
oh yeah I know the helicopters are still
they were they were going for sort of a
realism to them but it felt kind of bad
I didn't I didn't enjoy it I did
land a plane though which was really fun
I got a plane and I had to land it and I
I didn't realize that it had lights on
it so I was using my night vision in the
dark and I had to like land a plane on a
strip and I managed to land it oh my God
that was pretty that was that was pretty
cool that was like that was your
highlight of the entire day that was
probably my highlight playing it was uh
Landing that plane okay I felt pretty
good about that all right so we're in
the oh God that's going to blow fck
engage
okay there's somebody I think there's
enemies up there wow that is a mouthful
of a name there
um primy frit zeld aka Mr the wow player
that guy
deserves that is a damn um he wants to
know how big is this map is it Skyrim
big GTA big or Witcher 3 big I'm trying
to think hold on let's see so Skyrim big
is actually not that big Skyrim's
actually pretty restrained um GTA 5 is
pretty big I think 3 might be bigger
than GTA though I actually don't know I
think Witcher 3 is I think I think it
has the biggest map to my knowledge uh
no the the
biggest if you kind of put all those
worlds together in one spot I think
that's kind of yeah so this is the map
right here provided I don't hit any of
those icons but yeah this is basically
the
entire uh map definitely bigger than sky
yeah def definitely bigger than Skyrim
uh
here probably bigger than GTA it's a
little Skyrim and GTA I'd say are a
little more condensed in their um what
to do for the square footage this seems
to stretch things out a lot more it's
kind of going for more of a
scope um than compacting
everything ah who's hitting
me someone in the chat Jamie says it's
smaller than Witcher so uh I don't know
if that's true but um sure why not we'll
take we'll take your one for
it o That's
Cho so what are you trying to do right
now you're trying to hack a network I'm
trying to yeah try to hack into some
network over here but I think I may have
bitten off more than I could
chew there we
go how do you feel about just the the
straightforward Mission like objectives
so far I like this sort of game like I
like the sort of way to where you can
kind of approach any mission that you
want like it it kind of reminds me a
little bit of uh I would say Hitman a
little bit oh boy okay I'm down so cuz
like you know in Hitman how you can
literally approach any mission in any
style you want you can be stealthy or
you can go in guns blazing it's exactly
that with this okay so you can literally
play in any form that you wish but I
don't know it's it's so much more
satisfying when you're playing with
people than AI uh subjects because it's
just the AI at times like I was playing
this morning and there was a moment
where there were guards and my AI
companions literally walked across the
field in front of these dudes but
because I didn't get spotted yet the AI
didn't count that so they're looking at
my guys my guys are looking at them but
they just Mosey on past each other and
no one nothing happened I'm just like
are you kidding me so it's I don't know
man it's there are times
where like this game is made to play
with friends or or even just people
online Cooper I really I kind of find
that a bummer uh
though because that's something that I I
always felt Tom Clancy games like Ghost
Recon and uh like you wish it was
optional the the older uh Rainbow Six
games was the the squad AI was always
like pretty good or you know um at least
you had like a lot of options to give
them commands and control there was a
lot of uh control you had over your
squad and I thought that was sort of
like a huge appeal of those games and it
feels like the AI Squad in this game is
not
really that good and there's it's pretty
Limited in what you can have them do and
I think that's because they expect you
to play with your friends in which case
you can kind of do whatever you want
with your friends and communicate
directly but I I do miss that sort of
a more um single player experience where
I can I have like this squad that I can
directly command I mean I mean you could
give commands but they're so basic and
yeah they feel pretty basic
um I I don't feel like the real people
the way I felt like some of those
Rainbow Six games kind of made me feel
or those those other uh Ghost Recon
games right all right so we're going to
appro this a little more stealthier
since first approach didn't pay off too
well yeah we got to get in this building
so there's multiple entrances we can
takeing the the last Ghost Recon game I
really got into was um got uh Gro which
was a
Ghost Recon advanced War I only remember
the AC I don't remember the actual name
I was like for a second I was like wait
what was that game oh ghost right right
yeah yeah Advanced uh War Warfare right
yeah War cuz there's Warfare but there's
also like war fighter yeah or like was
it advanced fighter or Future Soldier
future you might be thinking Call of
Duty games now I don't know they're all
sound the
same uh but that was like a really early
Xbox 360 game and I thought that game
was awesome yeah that game was that was
cool really really cool wasn't that also
the first one where Ghost Recon went to
third person like over the shoulder cuz
always it was it was always first person
I believe so so know we're here careful
well they know we're
here I have a disc copy of the original
Ghost Recon um we can use this that's
good but I've never
actually I never played it because when
we had it I was like three three or four
like my dad Maybe not maybe not three or
four like you know five or six or
whatever remember my dad had it um and I
never actually played it cuz it
was son it's time you need to play this
game it's only three even even if he did
let me play it there's no way I'd have
been good at it you never know you could
have gone in there guns blazing and take
everybody out
yeah could have had a that six-year-old
me as a pro you could be at Esports you
never
know uh Jamie's wondering are we going
to be streaming breath of the wild so we
uh are not able
to uh stream much of the game right now
there's there's a lot of weird um
embargo restrictions we have but I know
once the game you can definitely look
forward to later on in the coming weeks
we're definitely going to be covering
that game extensively uh but we really
can't talk that much right oh
god really hate it when like I'm
randomly shot somewhere like that drives
me nuts so hopefully my teammates are
going to they're going to come save you
yes here we go here goes the guy so
luckily the AI can revive you um and
after given a few minutes you get down
again they can do it again for you
uh Bruno wants to know what difficulty
you're playing on uh I believe I'm
playing on hard I believe uh so this is
part of why I'm getting shot up for the
and then there's the one above it right
the yeah there's like the realistic I
think that's one with like no HUD so
which I'm I'm kind of tempted to want to
jump into because that was
cool trying to stay in doors here right
now because we got an enemy Chopper
outside a great Master Flash says
Advance Warfare was uh the 361 future
soldiers was the last gen one okay there
you go I think advanced war fighter is
the Call of Duty one
okay I think man I'm so
confused there's been so
many there's only so many ways you could
say that you like Warfare Warf fighter
Advanced
extreme amazing awesome awesome just
goes Recon awesome there we go G Rec a
we're running out of names guys we're
running out of ideas what other country
we're invading uh Switzerland Ghost
Recon high five great job well they just
start naming off the countries you fight
next yeah that'd be yeah that' probably
be the actual like Ghost Recon and this
one's like Brazil right so Ghost Recon
Brazil there you
go oh my
God yeah CU it was Rainbow Six Vegas
yeah yeah they did that
well still not able to connect with
people yet so that's a little
disappointing so we'll try to see if we
can connect to yeah that that is sounds
like everyone else is kind of having the
same issue yeah well PSN earlier was
mentioning for a lot of people that uh
you know some people were able to
connect earlier the day and then all of
a sudden they're starting to drop like
flies so luckily that hasn't happened to
us yet but yeah so if you are having
connection issues you're not the only
one and people are also reporting the
exact same thing
so that's actually
uh do a mission here we' located the of
am andells being used for training in
Monte destroying the STS will bring
training in the province to a halt okay
cool uh so there's a weapons Depot we
got to destroy someone is saying that
Advanced Warfare is the Call of Duty one
so I think it was war fighter was the
Ghost Recon that's going to be my final
answer war fighter was Ghost Recon War
Fair as Call of Duty do you miss games
taking place like in World War II like
do you miss those kind of actually kind
of I kind of do I was sort of
um I was watching a video where a guy
was like doing this really I like
watching like really weird internet
videos um do that are like two hours
long where people just like talk about
stuff that makes sense and this guy was
talking about all the Call of Duty games
and he was talking about
how uh the original Call of Duty
games sort of the the the newer ones
very much are about wanting to make you
feel like the hero right the badass and
the older Call of Duties were you were
never like the singular like oh you won
the war because you did a cool thing it
was more about you are one soldier in a
group of AI soldiers and I always
remembered like oh yeah like in those
games there were constantly just like
AI buddies around you that would like
help you and get shot and there's a real
uh sense of being part of something
larger and I kind of I kind of miss that
that that sense of of um the game that
scale like I haven't seen that recently
I feel like in a shooter you know what I
I couldn't agree more with you on that
and I feel like the game that nailed
that out of the park was the original
Call of Duty because I remember I
remember Parts Call of Duty you would
look at soldiers and would give you
their name and their Rank and if they
got killed they wouldn't it wouldn't
like pop up another same guy the same
name no that would that person would be
dead dead yeah and and the it kind of
hit home a little bit for me cuz I'm
just like oh man that person totally de
like oh you weirdly got attached to
those characters not because the game
tried to have a cut scene where it made
you feel attached to them because you
were like well I've been playing this
game for like 10 hours and there's
always been this dude with this name
next to me and all a sudden he gets shot
and he's not in the game anymore and
he's gone for good you're kind of bummed
about
it especially if it's like your fault
accidentally and you're like oh whoops
didn't mean to throw that grenade in
there so yeah like
I it's weird I don't know if I
necessarily miss the aesthetic of World
War uh 2 although I wouldn't mind going
back to it but I I do miss the
um kind of the tone that those older
Call of Duties gave I I don't think
there's a game that's tried to replicate
that since uh Call of Duty Left World
War II so I kind of want I kind of want
to see that back in some form I think
that would be really cool I've been
waiting to like dive back into like a
World War II because I I find those
games a lot more challenging because
you're not worried about using like
drones or high-end Weaponry like you
have to kind of like you kind have to
use yeah it's the knowledge yeah you
have to kind of use the knowledge of
your environment a lot better you have
to use uh your own like wits about you
on it like you can't just be like oh I I
have a drone I'll just call in an air
strike on this or that it's like no you
can't it doesn't work that way so it's
it's much more enjoyable to Wi you have
your back to a wall but because of your
own wits you manag to get out of it so I
I enjoy games like that
immensely uh I'm so I I think Activision
said that supposedly call of dut is
going to get back to its roots this year
but how would you but how would they get
back to the roots by going to World War
II is kind of the the I'm hoping
prevailing Theory but I part of me is
worried that even if they do go back to
World War II um I might I still might
not get necessarily what I want which is
sort of that scaled back um you're not
much the hero but you're just like a cog
in this larger War like I get the
feeling they might go for more of a like
a you're still like a grand hero kind of
thing which is what a lot of uh other
Shooters like you know Metal of Honor
kind of did um just so long as I like
like like the First Call of Duty for me
really made me like able to expand in
the map like I wasn't forced to follow
one particular Trail or one particular
like path I Wasing to kind of go around
what I could do I haven't felt that way
in a long time in a lot of Call of Duty
games or even you know recent Shooters
at all so I'm kind of hoping that they
if they do go back to that it's the idea
that oh hey by the way uh you can
approach this Mission any way you wish
like kind of mixing stuff like that like
recently I played Sniper Elite and that
kind of you know opens up to that idea
so if they can take something like that
and offer it in a way to where you feel
like you're just you're this one piece
in a big you know War Machine and you
know you're not Invincible but you can
be taken down but you're working with
other comrades in arms I would really
enjoy that I agreee that'd be rad it's
it's an interesting point about the the
VAR the way you could tackle it cuz yeah
that game totally did have this had an
objective but there were always like I I
I would find myself if I was getting
hammered and kind of like just dying
over and over on One path I would say
okay I'm going to go around this way
instead try it out the game never
um really like Express that in like a
very uh gamey way where it's like by the
way you could do multiple options you
know like it just it just kind of was
that way and you just sort of figured it
out playing right
uh like so long as so long as it gives
me that option to kind of explore and
take chances with different ideas that
that leaves it to a lot more possibility
of
it all right well this is a bottleneck
uh soul Hunter is wondering uh what you
guys can play how that's what a lot of
people were saying in the chat so we as
I said before I was fortunate enough to
get connected and stay connected so I
don't have much of an answer for you
yeah it it seems like it's just kind of
a it's it's really you got to keep
trying until you get connected once you
get in don't turn off your console ever
yeah just leave it
on oh no hostile
kill uh tanm is wondering if we're
getting frame drops uh you said it it
seems better yeah know I mean even
during these all these explosions I'm
not having much of an issue at all so I
don't know if you've notice anything or
not but no a couple people are saying
that they uh one person is saying that
the the frame rate for them has been
garbage but uh I it looks fine from what
I've been seeing you do it seems fine
there supposed to be a crate here but I
don't see
it trying to destroy a crate yeah we
have to destroy these these armored
crates so I'm actually run it here
quickly all hope there's not going to be
too many [__] in
here speaking of witch
oh get him get
him there we go there we go I was afraid
to shoot that one guy cuz's next to an
explosive Barrel I definitely don't want
to go up with him with that
Hile okay so for those of you just
joining us we are playing uh Tom
Clancy's Ghost Recon advanced no Ghost
Recon Wildland see I'm I'm so used to
not talking about that we're playing
Ghost Recon wildlands man I wish this
was Advanced Warfare oh I play that play
advanced Warfighter I play that great
game we are playing uh Ghost Recon
wildlands uh playing on PS4 we're still
trying to connect to other people we
might be the only ones playing now that
might be why uh that might be it to be
honest this game comes out pretty soon
right couple weeks yeah I think March
7th is when it come out that's that's
two weeks so uh yeah feel free free to
subscribe to us uh uh if you want to
check us out cuz we're definitely going
to be doing more coverage of this game
for sure uh when it gets closer to
launch that's a kill cool took that guy
down and yeah uh I am looking at the
chat so feel free to send any questions
our way the alarm what's our play the
alarm I think they already knew we were
here all right
so I think we're in a
safe down there we go cool
oh my God there's another guy up
there down
[Music]
down he's
down you'll be okay I'm on my way there
we go all right I got you covered so I'm
definitely this may be a a issue just of
uh working here and having so many games
to cover uh I'm definitely starting to
run an issue where I don't know where to
devote my personal time yeah right like
I've you know I've been playing Neo um
not as much as I'd like I started
playing uh for
Honor uh and then it's like dude like I
got a switch coming next Friday you got
Zelda coming yeah Zelda will come in
with the switch hang ining everyone's
coming
out I'm I'm probably like one of the few
people in the office uh who's interested
in near but I definitely want to like
check that out that seems pretty cool
here looks cool like I'm actually
looking forward to that too I'm I'm a
I'm a huge Platinum fan so I'm
interested in that one and then mass
comes out at the end of March so I'm
just sitting here like ah man I don't
even oh and Horizon I'm playing I got
Horizon so if you had to pick if you had
to decide only three games what would
they
be of all those oh man WRA your brain
around that
one well got this
guy
um
as I I unfortunately probably have to
forgo uh wildlands I know we're playing
it right now but uh just in
the I would definitely like Mass Effect
for sure I'm there's no like I'm such a
huge Mass Effect fan I definitely want
to devote a lot of time to that one
right uh probably Zelda I mean I'm
getting a switch so it's like it'd be
weird for me to like get my switch and
be like ah you know I I'll wait on I'm
not man there's no way I'm not going to
just like immediately want to play that
so I mean you never like Zelda Mass
Effect um destroyed okay maybe for Honor
because I'm I'm currently playing that
with a friend right now so and that's at
least one that I can just kind of
casually play like a couple matches and
then you know um Target down kind of
like turn it off uh the way we like
these other games are so like big open
world experiences that they they demand
a lot more time than that game does
right
I mean I'm definitely enjoying this open
Beta a lot more than I did the closed
beta just because for one a it's working
and also B is the fact that it's it's a
it's a feeling like a lot more solid
experience for me yeah so CU I
definitely remember even when the game
was working for me on the closed uh beta
there were just like there were certain
bugs that were popping up and yeah it
was a closed beta I get that but it's it
just is like you know it shouldn't be
happening as often as it you know should
h
for sure okay so we got one more crit to
blow up and then we got mission
accomplished so where is this
thing frag
out
cool all right nice it's the last of the
crates objectives clear you think it'll
help [__] the way I see it the less
these [__] have to shoot at me with
the better got that
right
all right what do we want to do next
well let's see here I'm waiting to see
if uh what the next objective they're
going to give us since still match
making in progress so we're not able to
find anybody at all so let's see here
[Music]
um so you head back into that town area
or we can probably head to Major Intel
let's head to Major Intel then yeah I
want I want to make sure we like I check
out the new map yeah there are a lot of
lights and switches up here seems like
it also has all the previous uh stuff in
the the Clos beta as well but I I
definitely want to see some of these new
environments going
on Chopper controls have still not
gotten the
best
yeah says fly low to avoid here we go
how do those guys stay on you don't have
any seat belts at all I don't know just
I think it's more terrifying is that
when your character got into the Pilots
he's like there's a lot of buttons up
here did he say that he said that like
that's always confident when a new
pilot who's shooting at us I don't know
what's going on it's like random I'm
getting random missile lock
on okay okay good
to so at least we got Min guns on this
thing that's good so order you still not
aim though at them with them there
there's no reticle like I don't I don't
understand that like weird why can I not
lock on to stuff like I would feel so
much better taking this into
combat than I would no it really just
seems more of a a way to get
around yeah you're
just now I'm just firing blind firing
hoping I hit something cuz it kind of
like Auto locks on to like trying to hit
somebody what they get okay let's see if
I can turn this around it's h oh there's
a I'm trying to oh my [__] hit things
with this thing no reticle there's
nothing there all the luck of the draw
here
folks
wow I kind of have to like fly like
super low kind I just angle
them
jeez guys throwing a grenade at me while
I'm flying a
chopper
I'm hitting a few guys so that's good
all
right okay so I'm just going to land
this
thing here we go Jesus yeah I don't get
that like why why was there never a
reticle for you know flying a chopper
like I just that kind of kind of escapes
my my my head about that I'm
like feel like they forgot that on their
checklist this really was really biz are
I'm not really sure what their uh
motivation was for that
one uh somebody is complaining about no
multiplayer in this game I assume
they're referring to uh PVP multiplayer
right yeah cuz I mean you definitely
want to play this with friends once it
starts working because it's it's just a
much better experience like it really is
um I never really did much um PVP
multiplayer and Ghost Recon games it was
always more about the the single player
experience the PVP from what I can
remember from the old days of Ghost
Recon it was a blast like a lot of my
longtime friends on Xbox I actually met
on the first ghost recon that was on
like on the original Xbox and
then all the other Xbox and all the
other Ghost Recon since then it's always
been a very fun experience for me mine
was um the uh Splinter Cell multiplayer
oh yeah Spies versus Merks uh what was
that uh see hold was it Pandora Pandora
tomorrow or uh maybe I'm trying cuz yeah
it's it kind of they they keep taking it
in and putting it back out and um should
we dare try to fly a [__] plane yeah
man do it come on I landed that thing
you can do it oh yeah it's fine yeah you
got the day way easier oh there's lights
too can all these guys fit in this plane
I guess
so
it's pretty it it is like at a distance
it's really pretty like if I don't get
locked on for missile locks every 10
seconds see this this to me is like
that's
gorgeous oh wow yeah that's cool
yeah
yeah a lot of really good uh console
games this year just like like
surprisingly good you know like I feel
like a lot of people were like oh you
know the the hardware has reached its
limit and I I feel like uh developers
are still surprising us with some pretty
good looking games on Console yeah I
think there's still some surprises
coming out there I
mean I mean there are definitely games
out there that look a lot like prettier
on PC for sure oh well of course but
like I know aren't slacking that much I
was playing Horizon with my friend I was
like this looks pretty good on PS4 like
the cut scenes in that game are like
jawdropping to me like they're like like
they're like cinematic yeah that looks
really good uh Horizon looks beautiful
like I'm shocked that game is running on
a PlayStation 4 oh yeah look at that
Landing dang damn that was awesome
almost hit a rock in a truck that that
was a perfect that that was good where
to find the plane
later all right right and then get in
the helicopter get the helicopter and
we'll move on to the next mission we got
out of that Intel which is this what are
we doing foreign military instructors
are working out of the program's main
training camp in Monte killing them will
bring training in the province to sco
waffles uh yes this game is four player
co-op we have been trying this entire
time to matchmake with some people but
no luck so far if you look to the top
right of the screen you'll see
matchmaking in progress it has been like
that actually they can't we have a
little uh oh yeah that's us never mind
front of it well sorry but yeah up on
the to PR screen it's been matchmaking
progress since we started and has not
changed at all since come on man this a
damn
Chopper and we got another guy stuck
behind the plane I kind of want to take
the plane again because it's just it
worked out so much SP asks uh should I
download the open Beta or should I
download Mass Effect 2 I mean I'm always
going to say download Mass Effect 2
regardless of the other game that's just
my personal preference I feel
like the answer is always mass effect
effect yeah I would definitely lean
towards that as
well yeah this pretty cool too I mean
you know I mean this is a game I'm going
to play with my friends a lot and Mass
Effect is a game I'm just going to like
enjoy for my own single player
experience and just really get to dive
into that story cuz I'm a big fan of
that series do do you have a like a good
group of friends that you know are going
to get this that you're going to play
with yeah in fact I just I just spoke to
them this morning about it and they're
just like yeah let's let's get the
division crew back together again right
right I actually had a group of friends
that all played the division and that
definitely made that experience really
fun um like launch
day uh I remember actually your deci I
had gotten uh back from work I was
working really really late so I got home
from work at like 12:30 and and the game
had just launched and all of
them were messaging me like yo man we
just got the division we're all playing
it and I was like ah you know what and
so like I bought it right then and there
downloaded it yeah all right let's do
this it's pretty pretty good it was like
a really fun week of of playing that
with them so if I had a bunch of friends
who were willing to do that with this uh
that would be awesome
um I don't really know though I don't I
I don't really know uh if my friends are
going to get this
one do you know how long this uh this
beta's up for uh I think it's open all
the way until Monday maybe I'm not quite
sure I've always known that he has a
Nathan says he doesn't have friends um
you know what that's what uh that's what
matchmaking is for that's that's exactly
it God I hate it when I'm randomly shot
and I just don't know where it's coming
from so far I'm digging the new area you
can explore like I I really am a fan of
the snowy mountains and just the overall
whoa what the that seems cool I am
Reviving myself yeah yeah Alex says the
open Beta ends February 27th with which
yes I believe that is uh that is Monday
that is Monday
cool I wouldn't give for a freaking RPG
right about
now they're going to be on top of us in
anothers well I'm going to do the
oldfashioned order my guys to start
shooting because ready when you order
your squad just start shooting they just
start taking out guys left and right
like it's kind of
ridiculous [__]
[Laughter]
balls
he's getting serious
now you know if he said that so calmly
too if there was a a sense
of like tongue and cheess like you're
supposed to hate these guys for saying
stuff like that maybe it could work but
it's it's real straight they're playing
it really straight well it sounds like
the the vo like the person who was
behind like the vo Booth told him like
yeah just say it like you would if
you're being shot at oh okay well uh
blah blah blah oh yeah that's fine yeah
that's good to
me they say it so calmly like you're
being shot at like save with a little
more energy
man all
right I mean I I am I'm I'm getting a
kick out of this game like I am enjoying
it for what it is um it's definitely a
game where you're going to get a lot
more mileage out of it if you play with
friends because AI is just so
damn
dumb yeah like it just really does not
help hisory all right breath
easy and also too is that you can just
bring all your custom characters in
together and that would be really cool
see different On's different variations
of like uh what their play style is and
what characters they've created out yeah
that's that's always really fun you know
I play a little bit with uh Jake Decker
and uh like you know like oh we're going
to go to work together to take out this
for like there's that's that is
satisfying for sure you
know kind of that that age-old uh adage
that uh everything's better in Co-op mhm
um I believe it I mean I think it
depends on the game obviously but I
definitely agree that there are certain
games out there excuse me that there's
definitely games out there that play a
lot better with friends and some games
out there that play so much better with
friends that it's kind of like damn this
game is definitely seems designed for
friends yeah for sure like that is the
that is the
focus rally up people rally up people
someone's asking uh you can disable the
entire HUD uh yes so you said there's a
mode that'll do it can you want option
yeah I'm actually going to I'm actually
going to turn it off let's I'm
curious where hold on I think it's
actually a different options
menu nope that's not what that's not
what oh man too many option menus there
all right
scale just show well it had a
preset just show yeah just just hide it
there we go there you go just hide
it just had it I do really like I played
this on
um PC when you go to The Graphic options
it'll show you a picture of what it
looks like and then it says oh when you
put the Shadow on it should look like
this it'll actually show you a picture
of what
exactly that that option will do to the
visuals which is really cool because I
think I think a lot of people you look
at it and you're like oh uh you
know postprocessing Shadow whatever
thing Dynamic does that mean like uh
okay like you just like I'll just turn
it on and then if it's chugging I'll
turn it off again right you don't
actually know what it does um so having
an actual like visual age show that I
think that is really clever and I I more
games should do that that is rad oh jeez
of course now with no hot I'm like like
you okay side got it I can't even well
it takes away the objectives now like I
don't even know where the guys are now
that's maybe a bit much although it did
seem it had customization so he probably
could set
it to be
uh kind of picking
shoes I do kind of like this though
without the H
I'm a fan of I'm a I'm a fan of no HUD
when I can get away with
it ah what the hell holy
smokes tell I'm really not a fan of is
just randomly getting shot he's
just engage
targets Open
Fire
H it is interesting that when you give
the AI orders to fire they literally go
on like a killing spree like they start
wiping out everybody which is
great let's see can you tell them to
shoot like a specific person you can
yeah you can order them to
attack okay you can order them to attack
random
characters uh is there any options in
terms of like silently kill or yeah so
that's um good good good
yeah cool shot that guy through the
glass of that
thing
all right I was going to say I was about
to ask who that a friendly but I
realized I don't think anyone there's no
are there are there any other like
friendly uh you can call in Rebels that
can help assist you um right and there
are like the the uh cages you can shoot
and then Rebels will come out and help
and help you they will come out and
assist you they'll come out and save you
um come on
guys fact I think I might have an
ability to call in some allies right now
let's see if we have that Beckham says
he's uh at their Grandma's not at their
XBox that's mistake number
one always choose video games over
family
[Laughter]
always especially if it's a game that's
going to take quite a while to beat like
Mass
Effect or does it introduce Grandma to
Mass Effect yeah exactly like have or
Grandma to like Ghost Recon she's like
who are you going to romance in this run
oh Grandma I like
Garis why couldn't you meet someone like
this in real
life damn it what the H this is driving
me
nuts and because like we don't have the
HUD on at the moment it's like really
hard you can't crawl underneath that you
could crawl underneath that God okay
maybe turn the H back on yeah I think so
it's great though to kind of like mess
with it though with no Hut on um yeah
and and it it did have customization
option so maybe like turn some things
on
um Brad Williams is saying I feel like
this game would be super dope with a
battle Battle Royale mode that would be
pretty cool just like Drop everybody in
the middle of a field of like 30 players
and everyone just like picks up weapons
if you can find them and just start
killing each other that' be kind of yeah
that would actually be kind of cool that
really cool be NE call good call
Brad everybody hold up we got hosti so
this is a purely single player well like
not single player but um like campaign
focused experience there's no PVP style
multiplayer yeah there isn't any uh to
my knowledge um I'm wondering if they're
going to maybe add that in later but uh
maybe so this is giving me the option to
kind of customize what I show just for
time wise we'll just select the
basic cool there we
go what
the you not see me walk in here is that
a oh it's just a random dude yeah it's a
random
civilian so yeah I just got notified
here on uh that the servers are now
going under maintenance so for all you
out there not getting connected there
you go so the are we going to get booted
no we won't get booted because we
actually are we are uh still connected
but it was weird that thing popped up
say servers are under maintenance so we
can't won't be able to connect with
anybody now so which is a bummer but
we're still playing so that's good we
lock down on that your own this is the
reality of to not some fantasy you have
to hope for these guys are the targets
ongoing maintenance ending
in
something they undergoing maintenance
okay they should have heard that back it
up they they might know you're
there that's do an everyday life for
these guys so they're used to it there
goes
Tim uh some people in the chat are
talking about uh uh Soldier uh shoulder
swap mhm uh can you do that in this game
uh imagine you should be able to right
yeah you should be able
to I'm trying
[Music]
to I'm really hoping to kill these guys
for enough Health breaks
Lo let me try to order my guys
attack they they're like fire fire fire
everything shoot
everything do what you were trained to
do
okay I'm indoors now so no more Magic
Bullets flying through the doors yeah
someone saying uh L3 R3 uh will
swap does that do anything mm nope all
right
interesting fire fire
fire oh boy I love
it at least you can make fun of it you
know it's not at the extent where it's
like oh my
God uh thank you David Swift thanks for
uh joining us we really appreciate it
man welcome
aboard
ah you know what's weird is that you're
hearing that you're seeing that minigun
going off you're not really hearing it
oh yeah you're right that is weird you
know it's just it's just like a
little huh yeah I don't know
it's too far to throw that so that is so
weird wow yeah okay all
right fire on him guys come on all right
now some saying right on the d-pad press
that one nope that is Supply Chopper
here should make it easy to intercept
and reot it towards the rebels let's get
hold up the Drone is up nope that is for
the
Drone couple people in the chat are
saying that the uh servers on Console
are back up now
uh we're still playing so I'm assuming
so but maybe we'll maybe we'll
finally get some people although uh
we've been going for almost an hour now
so we're probably actually going to stop
pretty soon yeah
probably you're going to be
okay it's funny they sto shooting the
moment I start to get revive but the
moment I'm back on my feet they just
blast you me man I'll be right there
come on man I keep hearing those Supply
Choppers overhead with this info you can
find and grab one of them for the
rebels mistaking that button
for they're coming right at us what's
the word boss grenade get to
cover that's interesting
so they' stopped shooting us yeah where
is everyone I don't know enemy
K get on that minigun uh I think
so nice now we're
talking oh can't really see anyone from
here unfortunately yeah and I can't zoom
in
either there's a lot of design decision
with this game that I'm quite confused
about the fact that you can't you have
no reticle on the attack
chopper uh you can't zoom in with the
minigun even a little bit so yeah just a
slight zoom in would be nice
uh there we go so much for
that blow that up blow that
up blow my stuff
up isn't that all right I think it's
gone now all right let's get this last
Target off that
hill and his mission accomplished yeah
everything went so smooth
let me call my guys in what's your go-to
weapon in the in this game so I haven't
gotten all of them yet but I would
definitely like to say
um got a man down what the hell I kind
of like the uh the AR is definitely one
of my favorite weapons in this game I
haven't found it yet for me to unlock
but I'm looking forward to grabbing it
soon I got you man just hang tight I'm
heading your way okay cool I always
didn't I feel like a game like this
where it the map's so open a sniper
rifle is almost like always required oh
yeah that mean I have one always
equipped this I'm assuming this guy's on
foot he's moving really
fast shoot him that's an
idea instu yeah there we go slow the
cartel down there we go gets out about
what
happened
I think there's actually a weapons crate
nearby I'm looking on my map right now
see a little arrow sticking up like that
the little blue arrow yeah yeah I think
that might be a weapons crate um let me
head back in there quickly and grab it
good
kill there's definitely one thing about
this game when you're playing with AI is
that it will randomly start calling out
stuff that's happening around you but
you're just kind of like okay what does
that mean to me like that doesn't make
any sense so sure yeah they're just kind
of yelling at you they just kind of
yelling at me for like like Target down
this guy's dead oh cool okay uh didn't
know there was a guy
there yeah
yeah okay it's in this building all
right what are we getting I don't know
it's going to find out
here can't give me the goods all right
well there's a
supply oh that was another thing that
drove me nuts in
uh Co-op is uh
everyone has to tag all that stuff
individually themselves
which is really annoying because it's
like okay we're both going to sneak
across different parts of this base and
it's like oh I just tagged a thing here
I guess after we're done come back over
here so you can do it too like yeah that
kind of sucks it was It was kind of dumb
not going to lie about that all right
let's get out of here it just adds more
like time and I don't know I'd rather
that not be a thing like you guys you
guys got time to take that out
right what
the what's up with that guy I don't
know all right and this is
why dual as uh
ues oh boy you're interrupting his
workout all right well we're just about
at the end here um is there anything
cool we can end this on anything
interesting you know what I'm going to
grab a looks like a tanks nearby and
we're just going to find like hopefully
find a base nearby and just wreck hell
till we die sounds good to me yeah let's
go end things nothing but
explosions it's getting dark that's
cool hang on I'll drive it looks like
there's actually enemies on the base up
the hill here actually on the left so
right come on everybody cool it's the
next guy where's the other guy he's in
the base I forget
him perfect there's a place right there
do
it so far so good so far
nobody oh there's a guy
it seems like it takes a minute for them
to realize that's not one of ours should
I do something about
that I wonder if there's someone I
should
call there's a siren there we go now
we're going to start getting some guys
here who blow up that
jeep this this is where I wish I I could
fire these guns on this damn transport
but your that's your ally shooting yeah
my great Ally shooting
so oh dang okay come on switch
[Music]
seats weapons free weapons
free not what I want to get back in the
tank no it gives me the option there's a
button to yeah it
should shoot that shoot the chopper
shoot the chopper take it out oh I think
it's going down
nice wish we got to see that more I know
right all right it's probably what we're
going to call it then yeah I think so I
think that's a good way to kind of call
it just causing some Mayhem and blowing
up other people's property yeah so uh
final thoughts on this this beta open
Beta here seems like it adds more than
we saw in the closed beta but it adds
more there's the frate to me so far is a
little more solid um and obviously the
extra part of the map is always cool too
it it this means a game that you need to
play with people it's just it's hard to
kind of really enjoy for what it is with
just AI you know Companions and so
unfortunately we weren't able to do that
today because the servers are buggy all
over the place but uh I'm looking
forward to playing this with my friends
I'm also looking forward to the other
games we mentioned earlier coming out
pretty soon oh yeah a lot of stuff
coming out so but yeah hopefully
hopefully the servers will be up pretty
soon so people will get to enjoy that uh
if you liked uh enjoyed this stream make
sure to subscribe to us we're going to
have a lot more coverage of this game
coming out in a couple weeks uh we're
going to have a review all that good
stuff uh also we're going to have a ton
of stuff on the switch next week when
that comes out so uh look forward to
that and uh yeah see you guys next time
we'll see you
again